bei uns bei bild wissen sie jetzt schon
mehr denn wir haben dieses papier hier
hier stets drin das ist das papier das
beim corona gipfel morgen mittag auf den
tisch kommt hier steht also drin was
dann am nachmittag oder wenn es wieder
spät wird am abend tatsächlich
beschlossen wird der korona plan für
weihnachten und sie können jetzt schon
hier bei bild live reingucken das ist
das papier über das der korona gipfel
morgen per video konferenz entscheiden
wird hier stets video schaltkonferenz
der kanzlerin mit den chefs und
chefinnen der länder morgen mittag fängt
das ganze an und was steht also drin
erstmal wird festgestellt dass die lage
ernst ist das kennen wir schon und hier
wird es dann interessant erst mal wird
der olaf scholz bund länder krisenstab
im bundeskanzleramt offiziell
verabschiedet offiziell installiert so
zu sagen hier wird also die korona krise
in den nächsten monaten gemeldet direkt
im kanzleramt in diesem stolz krisenstab
geführt von dem neuen corona general
breuer und da gucken wir weiter runter
auch das ist hochinteressant es geht
hier ums thema impfen natürlich denn wir
wissen je schneller wir bewusst dann
umso schneller kommen wir wieder auch
runter mit den hohen inzidenz werten und
dem druck auf die krankenhäuser das hier
das ist das ziel 30 millionen impfungen
bis zu weihnachten das ist schon eine
hausnummer da muss sich die regierung da
müssen sich die länder richtig
anstrengen damit das klappt damit die
impf schlangen endlich wieder
verschwinden in deutschland und das
versprechen der bundesregierung und der
länder ist ganz klar steht hier drin in
diesem neuen papier bis weihnachten soll
jeder der ein booster angebot haben will
dieses auch bekommen das also ist das
versprechen an diesem versprechen werden
sich die politiker wird sich olaf scholz
ab jetzt messen lassen müssen es geht
weiter mit dem status auch das ist
hochinteressant wenn sie geimpft sind
wenn sie zweimal geimpft sind sie werden
irgendwann ihren impfstatus wieder
verlieren das steht drin hier in dem
papier steht noch nicht drin wann das
passiert aber es gibt eine erste
hausnummer man wird wahrscheinlich nach
neun monaten zumindest in einer
übergangszeit zunächst nach neun monaten
seinen kompletten im status dann wieder
verlieren man muss sich also auf
frischen ostern lassen das steht
ebenfalls drin in diesem wichtigen
papier wir schauen runter hier geht es
jetzt um die regeln für weihnachten
zweig zweig plus und so weiter also
zweig plus wird gelten flächendeckend
bundesweit steht hier eine bundesweit
zweig vor allen dingen kinos theater
restaurants plus aktuellen test also
zwei geht los in all diesen
einrichtungen bundesweit und dann gilt
zwei geht natürlich vor allen dingen im
einzelhandel dort wird es incidents
unabhängig angewandt also dass ihr das
ist das entscheidende wort egal wie hoch
die korona zahlen irgendwo sind in den
regionen überall zweig im einzelhandel
also nix geht in geschäften für geimpfte
auch das steht drin in diesem papier das
morgen beim corona gipfel auf den tisch
kommt außerdem strenge kontakt
beschränkung für ungeübte und
einschränkungen bei großveranstaltungen
all das wird morgen der korona gipfel
entscheiden zuletzt für alle schüler und
schülerinnen in deutschlands schulen
gilt wieder eine strenge masken pflicht
am platz in allen klassen am platz also
all das ist drin in diesem corona paket
hier in diesem papier in diesem entwurf
die beschlussvorlage für den morgigen
corona gipfel heute schon bei bild live